ben oui et je dois dire que au départ
vous avez une solide formation classique
vous avez été à la commune france
j'étais engagé ses tanks mais il
française trois ans de conservatoire
ces temps de commencer ça fait tout de
même dix ans d'études solide qui ne veut
pas dire par là que je sois
extraordinaire blanc fin quelques places
10 ans de communion quotidienne des
grands classe avec grand classique oui
mais qu'est ce que vous jouiez à la
comédie française comme style de rôle et
bien j'aurais voulu jouer les vallées
j'aurais voulu jouer les scapin tous ces
types très malin et on ne nous a jamais
fait jouer et à cause de mon physique
on m'a tout de suite mais dans les petit
rondouillard contre ce qui est très
humiliant et on vous dit toujours d'être
content vous avez un emploi
les cocus il n'en manque pas dans
molière vous savez tous les rôles voyant
vite au revoir et parce qu'une rondeurs
mais ne peut pas jouer demi non non tout
ce qui est beau tout ce qui est glorieux
cfi fait les ridicules alors surtout en
matinée classé peuvent-ils vraiment ces
pays